c'est un acteur de la cyber sécurité sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines un nouvel acteur auxi box une
start up créée par françois fugace et je
suis avec vous justement bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes fondateur de cette start
up
elle a été créée qu'en et en quoi
consiste cette activité alors auxi boxe
a été créé en 2014 avec une mission
simple qui est de pouvoir garantir à
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur taille leur capacité à récupérer
toutes leurs données et à redémarrer
tout leur système
après un sinistre quels qu'ils soient et
y compris après une cyberattaque look
cibox elle est là alors look si bon que
ça effectivement c'est un de nos modèles
saas est un modèle qui est étanche et
ignifuges dont qui amène aussi un niveau
de sécurisation en local qui est qui est
assez important on a des modèles qui
peuvent être déclinés pour tout type de
problématique pour tous types
d'entreprises dont qui peuvent démarrer
sur des modèles extrêmement léger puis
aller vers des très gros système on va
stocker plusieurs pétaoctets de données
alors vous l'idée c'est que vous arrivez
pas après l'attaqué où pendant l'attaqué
vous arriver avant la taxe et ça alors
on arrive avant l' attaque dans le sens
effectivement il faut que nos solutions
soient soient déployées avant l' attaque
donc elles vont permettre d'historiser
l'intégralité des données de
l'entreprise donc ces données elles
peuvent être stockées sur sur différents
types de supports peuvent stocker sur
des menaces elle peut être stockée sur
des serveurs des savoirs physique et ça
va au virtuel des postes de travail je
pense qu'on a tous des données sur sur
nos ordinateurs portables par exemple
c'est le cas dans la plupart des
entreprises donc nous on va être capable
d'absorber intégralité de ses données et
de les restituer après une attaque et
également de redémarrer les systèmes en
un clic après une attaque
vous êtes combien au sein de cette start
up à auxi boxe on est 10 à l'heure
actuelle et on existe depuis 2000 14 10
personnes c'est quel métier on retrouve
dans cette start up
alors on retrouve des ingénieurs
évidemment j'en suis j'en suis un
moi-même on retrouve des techniciens
également pour assurer le support et
l'opération de nos deux
de nos solutions et on retrouve des
rôles commerciaux et marketing pour
évidemment assurer la diffusion de
solutions
on sait que la cybersécurité c'est un
enjeu fort c'est dans les années déjà
depuis deux trois ans dans les
prochaines années aussi ça va devenir un
enjeu encore plus important
quelles sont vos perspectives de
développement dans ce contexte la roxy
boys réalise plus de 60 % de croissance
par an depuis plusieurs années
maintenant notre notre objectif et nous
internationalisé
cette année on peut en bénéficier à
saint quentin en yvelines d'un
accompagnement extraordinaire de la part
des équipes de l'agglomération est
également on peut rayonner facilement
sur l'écosystème extrêmement riche en
cybersécurité à saint quentin et plus
largement de toutes les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines
nos perspectives ça va être de créer au
cours des trois prochaines années
plus de 30 postes sur le pôle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et également
sur notre second site de toulouse
françois fugace merci beaucoup merci à
vous président et fondateur d'auxi boxe